son las 8 y 30 de la noche en bogotá
quito de lima y continuamos en directo
américa edición nocturna seguimos
repasando los principales hechos del día
a ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía y
vamos con los titulares de esta jornada
se mantiene el debate en eeuu por la
venta y porte de armas en declaraciones
el presidente de joe biden llamó a
prohibir la venta de armas de asalto a
particulares y añadió que el congreso
debe hacer algo a raíz de los recientes
tiroteos entonces igual de tenemos
detalles desde washington
producía controla el 20% del territorio
ucraniano tras 99 días de ofensiva
militar así lo indicó el presidente
volodymyr selenski entretanto continúa
la ofensiva en la ciudad de severodonezk
la última gran urbe del donbass que
sigue en manos de quien pero que podría
caer bajo el control ruso en cualquier
momento
amnistía internacional denunció que el
gobierno salvadoreño ha cometido graves
violaciones a los derechos humanos en el
marco del régimen de excepción vigente
desde finales de marzo al tiempo que
advirtió sobre la posibilidad de una
responsabilidad penal internacional la
ong asegura que al menos 23 personas han
muerto bajo custodia estatal tenemos
análisis
[Aplausos]
[Música]
comenzamos en eeuu donde el presidente
joe biden pidió que se prohíban las
armas de asalto y los cargadores de alta
capacidad mientras continúa el debate
bipartidista sobre el control de armas
de fuego el mandatario aseguró que ya es
suficiente y solicitó que también se
refuerce la verificación de antecedentes
de los potenciales compradores
tenemos que prohibir las armas de asalto
y los cargadores de alta capacidad si no
podemos prohibir las armas de asalto
entonces debemos elevar la edad para
comprarlas de 18 a 21 años reforzar los
controles de antecedentes promulgar
leyes de almacenamiento seguro y leyes
de bandera roja derogar la inmunidad que
protege a los fabricantes de armas de la
responsabilidad abordar la crisis de
salud mental
profundizará en el trauma de la
violencia con armas de fuego y como
consecuencia de esa violencia son
medidas racionales y de sentido común
desde washington cristóbal vázquez
corresponsable france24 nos dio más
detalles de las declaraciones de biden
dijo que el pueblo americano entiende
entiende que la cultura del
estadounidense es del porte de armas
pero le pidió hacer conciencia para que
haya una prohibición en el porte y la
compra de armas de asalto enfatizó en
este compra y venta de armas de asalto
porque son precisamente estas armas las
que se han usado en los recientes
tiroteos en tulsa en buffalo y en balde
además del más sangriento de todos en la
historia reciente de eeuu que fue
también en los ángeles el presidente joe
biden dio unas cifras bastante
alarmantes dijo por ejemplo que desde el
tiroteo no balde se han reportado 20
tiroteos más en eeuu lo que pasa es que
no llegan a los medios de comunicación
dijo por ejemplo que más niños mueren de
policías al año en eeuu por causa de
tiroteos y que precisamente la causa
número uno de muertes en los niños son
los tiroteos que tiene que parar esta
tendencia esta realidad en eeuu
el presidente yo vaya al senado
específicamente que por favor haga algo
cualquier cosa pero que haga algo porque
cada vez que él va y visita un lugar
donde un tiroteo eso es lo que le piden
los ciudadanos por favor haga algo para
detener esta situación
vamos ahora hasta ucrania el presidente
vuelo de unirse lens que informó que un
20 por ciento de su país se encuentra
bajo el control ruso el mandatario
explicó que esa superficie equivale a
125 mil kilómetros cuadrados al tiempo
que denunció que unos 300.000 kilómetros
cuadrados están infestados de minas
plantadas por rusia selenski pidió más
armas a la comunidad internacional
justamente hoy reinó unido- prometió
enviar misiles de mediano alcance
sumándose a eeuu y alemania para equipar
y equipar al país con armamento capaz de
derribar aviones y destruir artillería
la situación en el este de nuestro país
es muy difícil donde en la actualidad
rusia ha reunido todas sus tropas todo
lo que tienen cerca de 100 personas
mueren cada día y unos cientos de
personas entre 450 y 500 resultan
heridas cada día y estamos agradecidos
por la ayuda que estamos recibiendo a
cada hombre y mujer pero es necesario
aumentar los suministros de armas porque
es en los campos de batalla de ucrania
donde la libertad de europa y todas sin
excepciones se determinarán y limpia por
el secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg aseguró que la guerra en
ucrania será larga y desgastante tras su
reunión en la casa blanca con el
presidente white en el funcionario
destacó que depende únicamente de quiere
decidir si se de territorios si es que
llega el momento de negociar y que la
obligación de la otan es ayudar a ese
país a defender su soberanía
y
las guerras son por naturaleza
impredecibles y por lo tanto solo
tenemos que estar preparados para el
largo plazo porque lo que vemos es que
esta guerra se ha convertido en una
guerra de desgaste en la que los
ucranianos están pagando un alto precio
por defender su propio país en el campo
de batalla
cambiamos de tema el gobierno yemení y
los rebeldes útiles llegaron a un
acuerdo para renovar por dos meses más
la tregua que comenzó en el pasado mes
de abril la decisión fue anunciada y
celebrada por el enviado especial de la
onu a dicho país es sin embargo una
parte de la población sigue sin confiar
en el cese al fuego y sigue inmersa en
la incertidumbre producto de un
conflicto que se ha prolongado durante
más de siete años
una decisión responsable y valiente la
onu celebró la renovación de la tregua
entre el gobierno yemení y los rebeldes
su pies me gustaría anunciar que las
partes en conflicto han aceptado la
propuesta de naciones unidas- de renovar
la actual tregua en yemen por dos meses
más la tregua de este conflicto que se
ha prolongado por más de siete años
comenzó el 2 de abril y según ha dicho
la onu ha representado un cambio
significativo en la trayectoria de la
guerra las víctimas civiles se han
reducido significativamente según varias
ongs durante el primer mes el número de
muertos y heridos bajó en más del 50% y
los vuelos comerciales se han reanudado
tras años de cierre pero no todos son
celebraciones las partes enfrentadas se
han acusado en numerosas ocasiones de
violar el acuerdo sobre todo en la
ciudad sureña de taiz donde los útiles
han bloqueado varias provincias
controladas por el gobierno para matar
las carreteras que conducen a la ciudad
de taiz aún están cerradas mientras que
la onu se mantiene en parcial y no se
atreve a nombrar a la parte que
obstaculiza el proceso de levantamiento
del sitio detalles
los habitantes detalles ya no son
optimistas sobre la tregua ya no creen
en ella el conflicto en yemen estalló
cuando los rebeldes tomaron saná en 2014
y desde entonces la guerra ha dejado
cientos de miles de muertos y millones
de desplazados
pasamos al salvador la ong amnistía
internacional alertó que el gobierno del
presidente en allí buque le ha cometido
graves violaciones a los derechos
humanos en medio del régimen de
excepción vigente desde finales de marzo
al tiempo que advirtió sobre la
posibilidad de una responsabilidad penal
internacional la organización expone que
al menos 23 personas detenidas han
muerto en custodia del estado más
temprano hablamos con erika guevara
rosas directora para las américas de
amnistía internacional que nos explicó
además de las denuncias por detenciones
arbitrarias que otros delitos se han
registrado
y es importante señalar que de un
periodo de un poco más de dos meses y
desde que inició la implementación de
este régimen de sección se han detenido
a 38 mil personas y en la mayoría de los
casos se trata de detenciones
arbitrarias que no cuentan con órdenes
de aprensión o situaciones en flagrancia
pero además han visto internacional a
través de la investigación que hemos
hecho también hemos documentado casos de
violaciones han debido proceso a la
presunción de inocencia a la defensa
adecuada en procedimientos judiciales
hemos por ejemplo verificado que las
audiencias que se dan de estas personas
detenidas que se presentan ante la
autoridad judicial son audiencias
sumarias de entre 300 y 500 personas con
un par de defensores públicos que no
conocen ni siquiera de los casos además
hemos recibido informes de tortura y
malos tratos sobre todo en la detención
de menores de edad de niños niñas y
adolescentes que han sido detenidas en
el contexto del régimen de excepción y
pues las 23 personas que se conocen que
por lo menos han muerto bajo custodia de
las autoridades
dado ninguna explicación ni siquiera que
hayan informado directamente a sus
familiares en nicaragua la asamblea
nacional de ese país de mayoría
oficialista canceló las personalidades
jurídicas de otras 96 ongs el
legislativo argumentó que dichas
organizaciones no estaban registradas
como agentes extranjeros con esto ya son
440 las organizaciones civiles sin fines
de lucro suspendidas desde diciembre de
2018 la decisión fue tomada por la
asamblea a petición del gobierno del
presidente daniel ortega y recibió el
carácter de votación urgente este
miércoles la policía del país detuvo al
sacerdote manuel salvador garcía el
primer representante de la iglesia
católica llevado preso
meta la compañía matriz de facebook
enfrenta una gran reorganización a raíz
del anuncio de sheryl sandberg la
directora de operaciones del grupo que
se retirará en la segunda mitad del año
cuando el actual director de crecimiento
javier oliván la reemplazará en sus
funciones más detalles a continuación
para algunos sheryl sandberg es la mujer
más poderosa de la tecnología y su
salida de la dirección de meta marca el
fin de una era según el fundador de
facebook por encima de todo le estoy
agradecido por todo lo que ha hecho por
construir meta
sheryl sandberg se graduó en harvard
trabajó para el banco mundial para la
consultoría mckenzie y para google
cuando llego a facebook en 2008 la
empresa no era rentable por lo que se la
considera responsable del éxito
económico y comercial de la compañía
tecnológica meta es una de las
corporaciones más poderosas del planeta
alcanzó un volumen de negocio de 118 mil
millones de dólares y un beneficio de 39
mil millones en 2021
está claro que la señora sandberg ha
jugado un papel determinante en el auge
de facebook y ahora de meta
deja un claro legado al construir esta
infraestructura que ha convertido a la
empresa en la segunda mayor vendedora de
publicidad del planeta
una red social convertida en máquina
publicitaria los métodos de sheryl
sandberg no están exentos de polémica el
grupo californiano es criticado por sus
prácticas de recolección de datos
personales por otro lado me está sufre
una crisis de crecimiento frente a la
competencia precisamente en un mensaje
de facebook la directora de operaciones
reveló su partida
cuando empecé este trabajo en 2008
esperaba quedarme cinco años en este
puesto 14 años más tarde es momento de
escribir un nuevo capítulo en mi vida
un nuevo capítulo consagrado a proyectos
filantrópicos y a defender el lugar de
las mujeres en el mundo de la tecnología
sin embargo sheryl sandberg continuará
en el consejo de administración de meta
el reino unido se llevaron a cabo las
celebraciones en el primero de los
cuatro días en los que se conmemora el
jubileo de platino de la reina isabel
segunda es decir sus 70 años como
monarca pese a que hoy participó en las
actividades la casa real informó que
mañana no estará presente en el servicio
de acción de gracias en la catedral de
san pablo con tan sólo 25 años isabel
segundo asumió el trono tras la muerte
de su padre el rey jorge sexto veamos
más de su vida
nacida en 1926 la reina isabel segunda
nunca estuvo destinada a gobernar pero
sólo diez años después cuando su tío
eduardo octavo abdicó por amor su padre
jorge sexto ascendió al trono la
princesa heredera se tomó en serio su
nuevo papel conduciendo una ambulancia
para el ejército británico en la segunda
guerra mundial y entendiendo sus deberes
por venir aire kraft
declaró ante todos ustedes que toda mi
vida sea larga o corta estará dedicada a
su servicio y al de nuestra gran familia
imperial a la que todos pertenecen así
que hable
la repentina muerte de su padre hizo que
isabel se convirtiera en reina en
1952 con sólo 25 años al año siguiente
ella y el duque de edimburgo dieron una
vuelta al mundo de seis meses por la
commonwealth incluyendo la primera
visita de un monarca británico a
australia y nueva zelanda ha viajado más
que cualquier otra persona que haya
llevado la corona sin embargo su reinado
ha sido tumultuoso incluyendo el
conflicto norirlandés
varias recesiones y el colapso del
imperio británico en 1992 tres de los
matrimonios de sus hijos dieron paso al
escándalo y al divorcio generando una
gran cantidad de mala publicidad la
muerte de la princesa diana en 1997
provocó una oleada de dolor público la
reina tardó en sumarse pasó una semana
antes de que se dirigiera a la nación y
diera la orden de ondear las banderas a
media asta
quiero rendir homenaje a diana yo misma
era un ser humano excepcional y dotado
en los buenos y en los malos momentos
nunca perdió su capacidad de sonreír y
amar ni de inspirar a los demás con su
calidez y amabilidad
james con el tiempo la popularidad de la
reina volvió a aumentar miles de
personas llenaron las calles para
celebrar los jubileos de 2002 y 2012 y
el entusiasmo por la realeza aumentó con
los matrimonios de sus nietos y los
nacimientos de sus bisnietos cada vez
más frágil y con recientes brotes de
enfermedad y tras la pérdida de su
marido el duque de edimburgo las
apariciones públicas de la reina son
ahora cada vez más escasas
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo américa les agradecemos que nos
hayan acompañado y los invitamos a
continuar con nosotros que ya llega a
migrantes con juliette y riaño feliz
noche para todos
[Música]